più alti
[Musica]
piano piano
stai di nuovo mangiato di nascosto o no
che cosa te lo fa pensare lei vede è per
niente guarda la cerniera ti ho detto ma
c'è dietro gli ho detto
e quello che cos'è io sono i croccantini
di berlino vedi
lo sapevo che stava nascondendo del cibo
dai danni un po che a me adesso almeno
noto non solo x men berlino
se qualcuno ha chiuso la porta e
qualcuno ha chiuso la porta a chiave ma
sarà stato il vento
guarda la tabella dei colori voi avete
capito vero e la tabella dei colori di
pofi playtime di a chi vuol che ora
dobbiamo trovare la combinazione di
colori giusta per uscire da questa
stanza o no preferisco mangiare gassman
ruba y
[Musica]
guardiamoci poi intorno per trovare i
colori ad esempio uno dei colori può
essere celeste 1 e verde c'è anche il
blu qui oltre al celeste e anche rosa
guarda l'orologio quindi forse sarà
verde celeste blu rosa ok proviamo
presto quindi abbiamo detto verbeck
celeste blu blu e rosa ferrosa
suo tempo romanismo bravo
si starà di walkie po fuori prima di
scoprirlo dobbiamo dirvi una cosa
importante rivolto a tantissimo che
vogliamo dirvelo per annunciarvi lo vi
facciamo prima vedere il trailer e poi
vi spieghiamo meglio pronti per il
trailer in 3 2 1
[Musica]
un mistero da svelare
4 misteriose creature da scoprire
un'avventura che vi lascerà col fiato
sospeso
storie paurose a scuola di misteri e ora
disponibile per il pre ordine su amazon
[Musica]
sta cavolo di mister mia libro è ora
disponibile
su amazon siamo troppo
felici è un sogno che si avvera non
vedevamo l'ora di vista non metteva
motore tsi dirlo
allora si parlò già più paurose alcuno
di misteri è la storia di quattro
ragazzini due ragazzi di due ragazzine
che si chiamano leo tommaso mina e
alyssa compagni di classe o certo punto
a scuola arriva una su sull'ente molto
misteriosa è molto strana che assegna
loro una ricerca su delle creature miss
poi loro che le creature sono le nostre
e le vostre preferite sarebbe risponderà
solo due il lupo banda lo è i vampiri di
loro dovranno andare a cercare queste
creature ma dovranno anche risolvere un
mistero e anche voi potrete risolvere il
mistero infatti a me allora anche se non
vi piace tanto leggere vi assicuro che
questo libro vi terrà incollati
alle pagine fino alla fine perché vi
tiene col fiato sospeso volete sapere
cosa succede in ogni storia per ogni
storia che leggerete accumulerete dei
punti e alla fine del libro in base ai
punti che avrete accumulato potrete
leggere a quale profilo apparterebbe è
super divertente come se farete anche
voi una challenge partecipate anche voi
alla challenge assieme ai protagonisti
ma più solo per i primissimi
preordini
insieme il libro da cartolina
autografata da me è vitale quindi
preordinate subito il libro storie paolo
de scuola di misteri petreti che vi
appassionerà tantissimo non riuscire a
smettere di leggerlo cliccate nel link
in descrizione per pre ordinarlo su
amazon se l'avete preordinato scrivetelo
nei commenti ma ora presto continuiamo
la nostra sala zia presto questo
avete visto
dobbiamo con tornare lì credo proprio di
sì che portate che non mi rubi il cibo
in cucina
[Applauso]
quanto tutte le mie cose
permesso mai come la nostra che devi non
è permesso io ti amo
cos'è questo
l'esperimento sul giocattolo è fallito
lui
verrà a cercarvi
trova il fiore
poppy playtime lui verrà a cercarmi
ecco perché qua in casa nostra o forse
il fiore si mangia forse edibile questo
fiore lo si può mangiare
il grave bach
wow vediamo come funziona
wow
è bellissimo aspetta manca la mano ecco
la mano abbiamo la mano una mano
sinistra manca la mano destra da trovare
wow e se non avete ancora lasciato un mi
piace lasciate un mi piace perché se
questo video raggiungi 15.000 bps
giocheremo anche con chi si misti nella
vita reale adesso di un mi piace qui
entro 5 secondi come
caduta
vediamo se funziona
batti il cinque
sicuro
per poco e non ha funzionato devi
battere ci
facevano quella cosa
un pattern 5
e trovo divertente programmatico si è
subito trovare l'amore rossa adesso
presto abbiamo guardate c'è qualcosa vi
alla porta
per sbloccare la porta si va dai
tiri premuto
sabato
più anche
o no che cosa
facciamo adesso sempre immobile
perché credo che dobbiamo attivare
l'elettricità come nel videogioco
guarda io ho un impegno un impegno che
impreziosiva isola io l'impegno ha
lasciato il sopra che definire
troppo paura la vado a mangiare scuse
bene ciao
evitare proprio un fifone ci penso io a
risolvere costa challenge innanzitutto
cerchiamo una mano rossa tanto ora a
khimki non dovrebbe muoversi vero
proverò utilizzare il gran pac ok mi
così si sveglia 31
si è mosso di un millimetro
guardate un altro simbolo della mano
devo aprire la porta con il mio grande
pac ehi avete lasciato un mi piace se
non avete ancora lasciato cliccate mi
piace quando
avete sentito
sono comparse le chiavi che vedrete
presto prendiamola con il dottor raffa
ok ora che ho le chiavi proviamo ad
aprire la porta
di maggie non puoi farmi niente addio
la mano rossa la mano destra
ora il mio grappa che completo
ma al di là di
dove sei finito forse è salito al piano
di sopra capitale è meglio meno vito
vitale
succede a chi fuori la sorpresa un testo
o subaffitto stretta importato possono
mangiare
io ho finito i cracker non so magari che
stava portando su qualcosa da mangiare
no non c'è niente da mangiare non è
questo momento è sparito qua ho trovato
una mano da registrare ora dobbiamo
trovare al quadro elettrico io sotto per
quadro elettrico posso aiutarti torniamo
credo che bisogna coprirlo con entrambe
le mani però degli homo funzioni
sia messo
pure la fortuna ma non è che c'è chi
guardi qui no e non credo come non
crediamo sia
ora che hai attivato l'elettricità
dobbiamo cercare il fiore io ho davvero
dispiaciuto ma siamo qui come
c'è nessuno
avete visto qualcuno qua
no non c'è nessuno mi serva
ti guardi
c'è nessuno
gli uomini non equa al piano di sopra
spero che non sia il piano di sotto con
vitale senza il grand pas capitale non
riuscirà mai a difendersi dagli waki
anzi magari proverà a offrirli del cibo
beh non mi resta che controllare in
corridoio di là allora anche se è molto
buio e cir se hai visto di luoghi da
qualche parte
e
no circe sta guardando di lama di là ho
già controllato non c'è niente
vabbè magari se n'è andato via
dove sarà il fiore
coin camera non ho visto nessun fiore
forse è meglio se chiamo vitale perché
anche i vuoti potrebbe essere al piano
di sotto con lui
[Musica]
beh no ma che è successo
o duty e ci ha preso forse era tutto un
sogno
no a giudicare da quel suono lo avevo
già preso abbiamo perso la prima partita
ma adesso abbiamo un'altra possibilità
dobbiamo trovare subito il fiore dove
potrà essere penso il fiore possa essere
in giardino i fiori si trovano in certi
lo è di certo non è in casa
va beh tu vai a controllare in giardino
io contro il corridoio buio che dice
prossimo avrò capito ok ragazzi
stiamo per esplorare il corridoio buio
speriamo di trovare il fiore
seleziona
che cos'è
il fiore
il fiore abbiamo trovato il fiore wow
ora possiamo completare la salis
[Musica]
ma io in fiore sente ora calarlo a lui
beh
e a chi paghi
[Musica]
mi sa tanto che non mi fai piu paura
adesso
[Musica]
e così carino mi riguarda ho trovato
solo questi
[Musica]
ho già trovato io e fiore dove addio a
chi adesso stai per schiacciarlo
schiacciarlo guarda
[Musica]
era questo l'obiettivo della missione
trovare il fiore per i bisogni sono così
ciao ciao mini ai laghi giochi ora non
puoi più fare del male a nessuno
[Musica]
ti abbiamo sconfitto ormai a chi va chi
non ci fai piu paura
ma possiamo anche lasciarlo andare tanto
ora non farà mai del male a nessuno no
così piccolo ciao ciao
già legge i
vampiri hanno paura dell'aio il canto
delle sirene puoi prenotare pupo di lupi
mannari
ululano alla luna
queste sono alcune cose che scoprirete
nel mio libro stadio paolo della scuola
di misteri bra ordinatelo stupito per
risolvere la cartolina autografata da me
è vitale clicca ad esaminare il link in
descrizione vedrete che vi piaceranno
tantissimo vorrete incollati a lecce in
tutte le storie settembre vi piacerà mi
lasciavo qualcosa caselline stupidi
chiaro per vedere inoltre altri video
cliccate su quella che preferite
[Musica]